- It baffles me how many people
think that they're bigger
than they actually are.
(dramatic music)
I hear people say like,
well how do I get in
the New York Times?
Or how do I get that
meeting with that CEO?
And often times I just say,
one is better than zero.
The steps it takes
to actually get
to the biggest
places in the world.
Before you getting a
meeting with, you know,
Zucks or Cuban or Barry Diller
or whoever you're trying to have
a meeting with
in the business world,
well you've got to have
a lot of little meetings
to build up your cadence.
People are always like
man, you've been on Conan
and Ellen and the Today Show
and CNN and Fox,
like how do I get that?
And I'm like well, I also
did a thousand interviews
it feels like on videos that
got one or 19 or 137 views.
Like my PR people and all
my managers and handlers
are really pissed at me
because they're like,
why are we spending 15
minutes doing these blogs
that have six readers,
you know, every single day
and you're passing on the
stuff that we're giving you
to be on CNN or New York Times?
I still, even today, am as happy
and sometimes even more
excited to be on a podcast
or a video blog that's only
going to reach 100 people
because I'm always about
depth versus width.
Do you want to go wide or
do you want to go deep?
I want to go deeper
with my community.
I want to give back to
people that were fans of me.
And so even today, where
I have more leverage than I did
three or four,
five to six years ago,
to get bigger platforms,
I still live
under the motto of one
is better than zero.
To me, doing these interviews
is a process of the work
that so many people are
impatient and not willing to do.
Are you willing to take 10
minutes to get 195 views?
I am. I don't know
who you think you are.
You've not gotten the exposure yet.
When you have not
made your name just yet,
when you're still
making the climb,
when you're not paying attention
'cause nobody else is, 'cause
217 people watched the video,
I'm grinding when you're sleeping.
I did those 87s and 59s
and 137s and 813 views
day in and day out, day in and
day out, day in and day out
and continued to.
You might make a video
on somebody's video show
that has 89 viewers, but
one of those 89 viewers
may be a producer at
CNN or might be the CFO
of a big company that
you're trying to reach,
and so undervaluing
just that one view,
it needs to be the right view,
but it's one view,
is a humongous mistake.
It's about having the humility.
It's about not saying no,
even when you've made it.
And that the one is
greater than zero concept
is something I'm proud that
I continue to execute on.